all right Dylan
Dylan uh where'd you grow up where are
you from originally I'm from Louisiana
what part Lafayette Louisiana or a
little town outside of Lafayette called
bro Bridge
it's the Crawfish capital of the world
yeah I know it will
tell me about your family my father was
a little bit more abusive than most but
um pretty normal family life but um
what he did to me later on when he found
out that I was using drugs then it got a
whole lot worse for him but my early
like childhood was pretty normal
but once he found out that I was using
drugs then it then I went to hell in a
handbasket you know because I was
when I was 16 I was so when I was 14 I
started using from my like parents and
my grandparents pill cabinet you know
like the narcos and the hydrocodone
and all that stuff and so
you found a bag of it in my uh in my
truck when I was crawfishing basically
when I was fishing
and so he basically like you know
started hitting me with the shovel and
all that [ __ ] he tied my dog's neck to
the ground for like three days and put a
bunch of dead chickens around it's
around its neck and let it decompose
there for three days
and then after that he'd maybe shoot the
dog in the back of the head
and told me never to use drugs again
and eventually found more drugs and so
he sent me off to California
to the rehab program
right when I turned 18 too how old are
you now I'm 23. 23. yeah and you're
still using yeah
where do you stay now uh I'm staying at
seesaw I finally got a place to stay
finally oh you got housing yeah yeah
you've been on the street before that
yeah yeah yeah for four and a half years
yeah
and what neighborhood Skid Row or skid
row and in the tenderloin in San
Francisco oh really yeah how do you
compare the two
how about I compare this to the two uh
so the tenderloin is a lot more
condensed
uh tenderloin is a lot more like
I'd say they're drug dealing
organization is a lot better because you
have the the Hondurans running the
running the drug game
so you'll just have a street block full
of Hondurans
and they control the drug game and so
anytime like of the day you could just
go it could be like 4 A.M
yeah 12 12 p.m any time of day you can
go and get what you need
and so and out here it's kind of like
you got to find drug dealers and [ __ ]
like that but you know out there you
know where to find it
which one's more dangerous
danger says in what
a white boy getting hurt on the street
uh I'd say out here probably
especially at night yeah
yeah yesterday A guy got shot and killed
right in front of my door yeah I heard
about that
I heard about ice shooting yeah it was
right here really
and how do you make money how do you
support yourself
so what I would do was uh I mean for the
whole four and a half years I would
boost but what I what I found
particularly
uh useful was I would go to a grocery
store
and uh seal all their carne asada
I don't know how to say like carne asada
and I was I would take all of their
carne asada and I put in a backpack and
I go to Mexican restaurants and sell it
to them
because they'd have to buy anyway retail
because they're not like established
enough to have a distributor a meat
distributor
and so I would be there basically their
meat distributor for their all their
meats and stuff like that so I'd sell
them it for like five dollars each when
they're really like twenty dollar steaks
each you know what I'm saying
how do you like this lifestyle how does
it affect you emotionally
emotionally it's like anxiety
anxiety-wise it's hell
it's hell on Earth
there's like every day you wake up you
have to figure out like what the [ __ ] am
I gonna do to make money like like or
else to go to Walgreens and like you
know what's your typical day look like
you wake up and do a wake up uh get well
uh do you have some is it is fentanyl
your drug yeah do you have fat in the
leftover from the day before
uh usually yeah yeah yeah I've been
using fetty for so long that like I
don't even feel it anymore
so like two years so far your body's
used to it yeah
uh
uh like when I was first starting out at
OD'd a couple of times yeah
seven times
and those were only at the times in San
Francisco
and all those times were only off of uh
press Xanax bars
which have fentanyl which I found out
yeah so your typical day you'll wake up
you'll get well
yeah it's a typical day more money yeah
well
uh go out use the uh public
transportation go to up to North
Hollywood area you know any any way you
know
any of the
you know what I mean like the the train
station map I go out to Pasadena or I go
to uh
I go to Santa Monica or I go to Long
Beach and I just find a Rite Aid or a
CVS
just I what I do is I take my jacket
right I take any old regular jacket and
I would open it up and I'd take a razor
and I cut it open like this I cut it
open like this so when I walk in I could
just shove as many makeup items as I can
in each and each like you know thing and
I put my hands in my pocket and I walk
out
and you sell it to a fence offense yeah
do you have friends on the street uh uh
I try not to have too many friends on
the streets can't trust anyone you can't
really trust nobody now
but I do have a few like you know
yeah
but
I mean do you feel like you're
drug use is in some way uh
response to your dad's
oh absolutely yeah I remember when I
when I when I uh when he finally so the
reason why he sent me to California was
because when I was 18 I got caught uh
like two hours away from where I lived
in Louisiana but with like a little
baggy and meth in my car
after that that was it
you just put me on a flight to Costa
Mesa that was the last time I ever saw
him
and so
um
a lot of a lot of my use is because of
what he's what he's done to me I mean
everything was fine before I turned like
around 14 15 when he knew I was doing
drugs then he started upping like the
ante if you will like you would like hit
me a lot more like he would hit like
I remember he'd always hit me with the
butt of a shotgun like you know like or
a shovel
anything you can use but you know I
always I always thought that I was my my
fault you know because I was a drug
addict
and so like I
uh when I was in the uh the program that
he sent me to
I sort of came to terms with with the
fact that like you know it wasn't my
fault
and that like I had a disease you know
like I it wasn't my fault that like you
know I was [ __ ] up that way so I
wrote him a letter
I wrote him a letter saying that you
know
that I sort of forgave him but not
really forgave him for what he's done
because it'll always like you know
I'll always have that scar in my life
from what he's done to me but I'm like
basically I want to have a relationship
with him so and so I'll call him every
once in a while and you know
we're on a lot better terms than we were
do you have hope of getting clean one
day
I do
because it's not sustainable
I have has a lot of Hope with getting
clean one day
what are you afraid of
huh what are you afraid of well I'm
afraid of
I'm afraid of being one of these people
outside begging for money on the corner
with nothing just I'm afraid of
hopelessness
you know
what was your favorite memory in your
life my favorite memory of my life Ah
that's that's a tough one
uh my favorite memory I guess or series
of memories is just being a kid and not
having the
idea or even the notion that drugs
existed you know before I even knew
about you know pills or anything of any
of that
like that's my favorite memory like all
the memories I had when I was a kid when
I'd have paintball you know gun wars
with my friends when I was a kid like
those are my favorite memories before
like all this like drug [ __ ] started
happening you know
you been in love before huh have you
been in love before
yeah
I was very much in love for four years
did drugs complicate that oh how could
they not yeah
because I had to basically support both
of us because she wasn't good at making
money
so she would just sit back and let me go
into the store and take all the risks
you know and that's what I did every
time
that's ultimately why I broke up with
her because I was like you
you know it's just not gonna work like
this you gotta like put at least some
effort into like what we're doing here
or else is isn't going to work
but also it's she's also a controlling
megalomaniac so
I just fell out of love with her because
I guess I mean she was like there was
one time and when we were uh in San
Francisco where she was in crack
psychosis and I walked into the alley
that we usually slept in
and I found her like [ __ ] some dude
like both fully naked and [ __ ] and I
just kicked the [ __ ] out of this dude's
head
I felt bad for that because I knew it
wasn't his Pro his problem but like I
was just so pissed off at her and like I
never forgave her after that
because we had been together for like
four years three three years prior to
that like I never thought she would do
that to me you know
if you had your life to live all over
again what would you have done
differently
oh that's a tough one
I will I guess I would have taken care
of myself
like I would have wanted
I would have taken care of myself
how I would have wanted someone else who
I loved to be taken care of
does that make sense
it's perfect sense because I treated
myself like
as a person who
didn't didn't uh
need any love or didn't just you know
who didn't uh
I treated myself as a person who didn't
deserve it didn't deserve it yeah you
didn't deserve it you deserve nothing
but like destruction and chaos and
it's just
yeah do you feel like life is unfair
I don't
I feel like it's unfair to those who
I mean it's it's all about
I mean Heidegger
do you know about Heidegger
uh a philosopher or he said there's this
uh
idea that he came up with called
thurness
or throwness
and thrown this is basically the
principle that we're all thrown into
this world
like we don't have a choice whether
we're here wire black
whether we're a addicted to drugs
whether we're you know this or that or
this or that you know
you know some people have it better
obviously you know so that's
that's how I I see it I think it's
unfair in that aspect you know some
people have it better than others
I think I won the genetic Lottery
basically by coming by by being able
being a male in
in one of the most powerful countries in
the world but I also feel like I didn't
win the genetic Lottery because I
have this like feeling inside me where I
want to use all the time you know
did you feel like you were loved as a
child
no
no
[Music]
I felt like so the way I felt was I felt
like my dad was an aggressor and I felt
like my mom was
a person who would just look look the
other way and let it happen you know
and so that's the way I was that's the
way I grew up
did you describe yourself as generally
happy
I'm a happy person I seem to be yeah
yeah yeah I I love talking to people I
love meeting new people you have good
head on your shoulders
yeah I
I uh thank you
um
it's just the circumstances I found
myself in just
like for I don't know how it got so
crazy like so fast because like what
happened was
is that I I came to California for the
treatment and then once I was done with
the treatment they just threw me out on
the streets
and so I was just homeless right after I
got out of treatment and then when I
called my dad
he didn't answer
and so nobody no I didn't know how to
reach my family or anybody and so I
stayed at home homeless for
about a year in Costa Mesa in my car and
that's ended up selling my car for money
because I had no other option pretty
much
and I just kept using from there then I
met a girl like she went to San
Francisco State
and so I followed her there
not knowing that San Francisco is going
to be probably the worst thing for my
addiction and stuff like that
and so
and then I moved back here with her
and moved back up there with her and
then finally we moved back down together
and then that's when we broke up
because I tried to stay with her for a
little bit longer after after finding
her with some other dude but I just
couldn't do it you know like my dick my
dick wouldn't even get hard for her
anymore
yeah
and that's that's when I knew I was just
like I can't I can't do it I'm sorry
you're not the one for me
Don what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
that's a tough one man
I'd say the most important lesson in my
life is just to
treat others the way you wish to be
treated
like the Golden Rule but
I feel like is much more to it you know
like there's
you have to
I don't know
I really don't know do you believe in
karma
a little bit yeah in a little
superstitious way I believe that
whatever you put into the world comes
back to you
so I try to do as much good as I can
you know and I hate the fact that my
what I have to do to get drugs
uh you know like often when security
guards are chasing me out the stores I'm
yelling sorry sorry I'm a drug addict
sorry sorry I like I'm crying I'm like
you know
that's [ __ ] up man you know because I
don't want to be doing that to the
stores and like you know taking their
products and stuff like that
and it's just yeah
all right Dylan thank you so much for
sharing your story
yeah no problem I wish you the best of
luck out there thank you man thank you